ces images sont tristement historique le
sinistre a eu lieu il ya déjà quinze
mois et partout en france des
scientifiques oeuvre désormais à la
future reconstruction à orléans le cnrs
est l'un des partenaires engagés dans
les études sur l' incendie de notre dame
cette mission est assumée par le
laboratoire de recherche sur les arcs et
aux matériaux les matières premières
utilisées par l'homme au long des
millénaires précédent au cours de l'
incendie de la toiture 400 tonnes de
plants ont été fondues ou transformés en
débris
c'est ce plan qui est étudiée ici chaque
échantillon de plomb possède des
informations qui concerne l'emplacement
de son prélèvement ou son mode au
transept la nef et le choeur avec des
précisions supplémentaires et à partir
de là une fois que nous aurons le
référentiel de composition chimique
déterminé grâce aux analyses
on va replacer chaque échantillon dans
son contexte de prélèvement pour mieux
comprendre le l'édifice pour parfaire
cette connaissance près de 300
échantillons de plans sont en cours
d'analysé dans ce laboratoire une
analyse physique qui ne détruit pas les
pièces collectées
nous allons réaliser un petit
prélèvement sur un des coins comme ici
pour le placer dans ce dispositif
d'abattement laser qui va permettre de
prélever des petites particules de
matière ils vont être transportés
jusqu'à ce second dispositif qui est un
spectromètre de masse
un appareil qui permet de détecter
toutes les molécules constitue en la
matière cela aidera à déterminer la
localisation probable du minerai utilisé
est à saluer l'apport de certains
artisans de l'époque médiévale le plus
stimulant c'est d'envisager le matériau
comme un moyen d'accéder aux individus
aux personnes qui ont vécu il ya
plusieurs siècles qui ont travaillé sur
le chantier qui ont travaillé dans les
mines pour produire du minerai qui ont
sans doute jamais vu la cathédrale mais
qui ont une certaine manière le vrai
pour l'édification de la cathédrale mi
octobre les premières conclusions des
huit groupes de travail embarqué dans
cette aventure de la connaissance des
matériaux de notre dame seront mises en
commun à paris une première modélisation
3d de la cathédrale sera ensuite
réalisée pour déterminer les
préconisations à suivre lors de la
reconstruction